Senator I'm looking at this and there's
two things that I'm thinking about I
want your your take on number one do you
agree with me that a new axis of Evil is
being formed right before our eyes and
number two do you believe that history
repeats itself
Shawna I do agree with you that axis of
Evil increasingly centered on Beijing as
you laid out is emerging it's emerging
in large part because of President Joe
Biden's weakness and his tendency to
blame America and our allies first and
of course history can repeat itself
we're no different from those who fought
in World War II or World War One or our
civil war the Revolutionary War who we
read about in the Bible because human
nature is timeless and unchanging
therefore we are prone to the same
mistakes if we don't learn from the
lessons of history and that's what Joe
Biden has not done almost every instance
you laid out there as a result of Joe
Biden's incompetence his weakness and
his tendency to blame America First Look
at the president of Brazil he's
left-wing he's critical if not openly
hostile to America he's kind of typical
of many left-wing leaders that have come
to power in recent years in Latin
America Joe Biden doesn't say a word
negative about them and what happens you
have them running off to Beijing or
welcoming Iranian warships in Latin
America that all gets back to the fact
that they think they can get away with
actions that are unfriendly or openly
hostile to America under President Biden
what do you make of this these new
alliances for example China and Russia
uh what do you make about China Russia
and Iran what do you make of the Chinese
brokering a deal with our former Ally as
far as I'm concerned Saudi Arabia and
Iran I never thought I'd see that or
Egypt helping out Putin or the UAE now
helping out Putin do you believe that
our allies these defections that these
countries are making a choice and they
they are betting that China is going to
outpace the United States and overtake
the U.S as the world's you know leader
uh and be the sole superpower if you
will of the world
I think increasingly we're seeing many
traditional American partners and allies
hedging their bets because they're
worried about American resolve and
strength under President Biden you
mentioned several Egypt Saudi Arabia the
United Arab Emirates Israel you know we
left president Trump we had peace
agreements brokered by America between
Israel and its Arab neighbors we were
hoping for an American piece of deal
brokered between Israel and Saudi Arabia
what we got is a Chinese agreement
between Iran and Saudi Arabia and again
what you see is President Biden creating
Daylights as he sometimes says where
President Obama used to say or
criticizing the governments of Israel
and Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates threatening for instance to
make Saudi Arabia a pariah all these
countries live in a tough neighborhood
they have security needs America has
long helped them achieve those security
objectives if we're not going to do it
they're not going to go away they're
going to look elsewhere and that's
increasingly why you see China playing a
role in the Middle East that is
unhelpful and harmful to America
interests Senator last question almost
daily now the Communist Chinese they are
threatening us directly they are
threatening our Navy in The Straits of
Taiwan or the South China Sea
International waterways what what should
the U.S response be to that
well every time China for that matter
Russia or Iran threatens our Navy or our
aircraft saying they can't sell heel
here they can't fly there we should
basically make that our new route that
we're going to travel to show China and
Russia and Iran that they can't bully us
more on the long-term front we have to
significantly increase our defense
spending and invest in the kinds of
weapons and aircraft and ships they're
going to deter China and Russia and Iran
and make it clear to them that not only
we have the resolve to defend our
interests but we have the ability to do
so as well Senator cotton great to have
you thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else